action to all the huge breaking
developments on the Korean Peninsula and
out of Iran we have Fox News national
security strategy Sebastian Gorka
retired CIA senior intelligence officer
and sonner on policy group
vice-president Daniel Hoffman let's
start with the presentation by Bibi
Netanyahu it was I think the first of
all I think he did it without notes the
single biggest Intel breakthrough that I
can think of in our lifetime your
thoughts yeah I think we if we're old
enough we think back to those pictures
during the Cuban Missile Crisis when our
ambassador stood up at the United
Nations and said to the Soviets
you're lying here are the u2 photographs
of the missiles that you've smuggled
into Cuba to attack us it was like that
but on steroids sure we're talking about
tens of thousands of documents half a
ton of information intelligence that our
government has confirmed that proves
everything that President has been
saying the Iran deal is a sham and the
Iranians want and are developing nuclear
weapons to use against the west and to
use against Israel it's a slam dunk and
as far as I'm concerned as of today
thanks to Bibi Netanyahu the jcpoa Iran
deal Obama's wonderful legacy is dead
mr. Hoffman beyond that now the world
has clarity to get out of this
ridiculous Iranian deal and even more
historic you see North Korean dictator
who not that long ago was firing
missiles over to Japan and threatening
Guam in the world in the United States
crossing over the DMZ meeting with the
South Korean president and I would say
Donald Trump played a big part in all of
that he did let me just make a quick
comment on the Iran deal there were
three elements of that that were really
a problem for us the first was the
sunset clause the second that it didn't
address Iran's development of ICBMs and
third that it provided influx of cash
for Iran's state-sponsored terrorism one
of the really interesting parts of Prime
Minister Netanyahu's briefing today
related to Iran's plans to integrate
ICBMs with nuclear weapons that
has to be cause for great concern for us
and I think what we're waiting for right
now is the US intelligence community
assessment of the rassa t of the
intelligence report I expect this story
to carry on in the days ahead Shawn yeah
what do you take on North Korea I mean
did did anyway if this is the typical
liberal thought process though dr. Gorka
oh we've got to kiss their ring oh we've
got to bribe them oh we if we're nicer
to them they'll be nicer to us it never
works the left-wing have dictatorial
propensity z-- themselves that's what
political correctness is political
correctness is in fact a form of
censorship they like to control other
people so they're sympathetic to
dictatorships whether it's whether it's
ugly over
the propaganda minister of North Korea
during the Olympics or whether it's
worshiping the Iranian mullahs and
giving them a hundred fifty billion
dollars they're simpatico with these
people so this is when it stops no more
appeasement
this isn't Berlin in 1938 this isn't the
Cuban Missile Crisis it stops on January
the 20th 2016 it should work for Reagan
it worked for for Churchill it worked
for it works appeasement fails mr.
Hoffman
yeah just one comment about North Korea
that I think it's really important for
us to highlight is the president has
steadfastly said that if this isn't
going the right way he's gonna walk out
and he's not giving any sanctions relief
until they agree fully denuclearize and
that's I think a key element here we've
made errors in the past or we gave them
a lot of aid a grin it broke down over
verification so trust will verify and
yes nothing until mistrust but verify I
would even say in this case yes amazing
times we're living and I'll tell you
that thank you both